Am Neujahrstag war die NASA-Raumsonde “New
Horizons” am Kuipergürtelobjekt Ultima
Thule vorbei geflogen.
Seitdem folgen Stück für Stück spannende
Erkenntnisse über dieses äußerst mysteriöse
Objekt.
Beispielsweise ist seine Gestalt, die zunächst
an einen bizarr flachen Schneemann erinnert
noch außergewöhnlicher als vermutet.
Doch das ist noch längst nicht alles.
Auf einer US-Fachkonferenz wurden jetzt weitere
spannende Detailergebnisse veröffentlicht.
Welche Rätsel um Ultima Thule konnten gelöst
werden und welche stehen noch aus?!
Alle wichtigen Infos bekommt ihr jetzt bei
Clixoom Science & Fiction - Hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich willkommen!
Ultima Thule - der wirklich mehr als mysteriöse
Himmelskörper, der sich im Kuipergürtel
jenseits der Umlaufbahnen von Pluto und Neptun
befindet - heißt offiziell noch immer 2014
MU69.
Er ist 6,6 Milliarden Kilometer entfernt und
das beträgt den sage und schreibe 44-fachen
Abstand von Erde zu Sonne.
Die Analyse von Ultima Thule ist für die
Fachwelt eine Sensation und Weltpremiere.
Denn noch nie hat eine Sonde ein Objekt untersucht,
das so weit entfernt ist.
Und auch, wenn der Vorbeiflug der NASA-Sonde
“New Horizons” an Ultima Thule extrem
präzise war, sind bislang nur wenige aufgezeichnete
Bilder und Messdaten zur Erde gelangt.
Und so werden wir wohl noch bis zum Herbst
2020 stückchenweise immer mehr zu diesem
Himmelskörper erfahren.
So lange wird wohl die Übertragung der Daten
dauern.
Hier bei Clixoom Science & Fiction gibt es
natürlich immer direkt die neuesten Erkenntnisse.
Bisher wissen wir über das seltsam geformte
Himmelsobjekt, dass es rund 30 Kilometer lang
ist und aus zwei Teilkörpern besteht.
Auf den ersten Blick erinnert es an die Form
eines Schneemannes.
Doch eine NASA-Analyse konnte zeigen, dass
Ultima Thule eben nicht aus zwei Kugeln besteht,
sondern das größere Objekt ziemlich flach
ist - quasi so wie ein Pfannkuchen.
Und schon die ersten Detailbilder zeigten,
dass die Oberfläche des Objekts weitestgehend
unversehrt scheint.
Vertiefungen, die an Krater erinnern und einen
Durchmesser von rund 100 Metern haben, wurden
bisher nur wenige entdeckt.
Vor allem am unteren Rand von Ultima Thule
zeigen sich solche kleinen Einsenkungen.
Doch sicher sind die Fachleute nicht, ob es
sich hier tatsächlich um Einschlagskrater
handelt.
Denn diese Einsenkungen könnten sich auch
durch andere Prozesse gebildet haben.
Rätsel geben bisher auch noch die länglichen
Rillen auf.
Nach der Vermutung der Fachleute könnten
dies die Grenzen der ursprünglichen Klumpen
bilden, die sich dann irgendwann zu den beiden
Teilkörpern von Ultima Thule verschmolzen
haben.
“New Horizons” zeigt auch, dass die Oberfläche
von Ultima Thule auffällig auffällig rot
gefärbt ist.
Spektralen Analysen zufolge liegt das daran,
dass sich dort organische Moleküle namens
“Tholine” ansammeln.
Das bedeutet so viel wie “schlammig” und
bezeichnet ange Kettenmoleküle aus Kohlenstoff,
Stickstoff und Wasserstoff.
Wahrscheinlich bilden sich diese Tholine durch
den Einfluss von UV-Strahlung.
Zudem entdeckte die NASA-Sonde auch Wassereis.
Viele Kuipergürtelobjekte bestehen daraus,
sodass dies keine große Überraschung für
die Fachleute war.
Doch es gab eine andere große Überraschung.
Und die haben Experten gerade auf der Fachkonferenz
“Lunar & Planetary Science Conference”
in Houston vorgestellt.
Denn “New Horizons” konnte auch festes
Methanol nachweisen, manchmal auch als Holzalkohol
bekannt.
Und das lässt selbst Experten staunen, denn
bisher konnte festes Methanol nur auf wirklich
wenigen Himmelskörpern im äußeren Sonnensystem
nachgewiesen werden.
Es wird vermutet, dass es sich auf Ultima
Thule aus Wasser und einfachen Kohlenwasserstoffen
gebildet hat.
Fest steht: Methanol ist für uns Menschen
giftig, ja sogar tödlich.
Die beteiligten Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
des “New-Horizons”-Teams jedenfalls sind
mit Feuereifer bei der Sache.
So wie die Forscherin Silvia Protopapa: “Das
Spektrum von Ultima Thule ähnelt einigen
der extremsten Objekte, die wir im äußeren
Sonnensystem gesehen haben.
New Horizons gibt uns also eine unglaubliche
Gelegenheit, einen dieser Körper aus der
Nähe zu studieren."
Raumstation in einem ausgehöhlten Asteroiden
- What?
Spinnerei oder realistisch?
Draufklicken und anschauen ist mein Tipp,
ansonsten: Bis dann, bleibt dran!